the parental rights in education bill
has officially passed the florida state
senate and even before being signed into
law has already made history as the
single most misrepresented piece of
legislation in perhaps the history of
politics opponents have dubbed it the
don't say gay bill prompting senate
democrats in florida to walk up and down
their office hallways chanting gay
gay
gay
the bill led mark hamill luke skywalker
to tweet the word gay
precisely 69 times
the bill impelled the ceo of disney to
donate five million dollars to gay
causes to plead with ron desantis not to
sign the bill
not to prohibit
the utterance of that apparently sacred
word
gay
but the bill doesn't ban the word gay
the bill doesn't even mention the word
gay
the bill just stops teachers from
preaching transgenderism and other
strange sexual theories to extremely
young school children in preschool
through third grade
why are democrats so deeply opposed to a
bill that would have been entirely
uncontroversial considered common sense
just five or ten years ago i don't know
which is why i've invited a democrat on
to explain it to me i'm michael knowles
this the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from doughboy2m
who says when biden is talking at any
given time and the sign language guy is
in the little box off to the side
interpreting waving his hands around the
sign language guy seems to be making
more sense that is an astute observation
i agree with you entirely now i need
help making sense of the uproar over
this law which is why i have invited on
my friend ethan berman ethan berman you
know him you've seen him on tv he is a
liberal california democrat lawyer
ethan thank you for coming on
well michael it is good to join you and
of course i disagree with your uh
entire premise of uh where this starts
but but it's good to see you this
morning well it's wonderful to see you i
you you are as far as i can tell
very intelligent
generally normal certainly by california
standards normal common sense-headed
person and yet
you oppose
this law in florida explain to me the
problem with the law
well let's let's start with the
presentation of the law in the first
place there is no sex ed curriculum for
k-3 in the state of florida now nothing
in this bill addresses the curriculum in
the state of florida this is a classic
red meat piece of legislation for a
rabid base that hates the idea of
anybody who is different from them and
so it was really a bill that addressed
nothing that was relevant in the florida
schools in the first place well okay
then i'll pause you there for one second
if the bill doesn't actually take on
anything that is going on in the schools
then what's the big deal why the uproar
about it it's going to be completely
ineffective so who cares
yeah the big the big deal is this is we
already have a minority group
of lgbtq families and students so for
example one of the things that one of
the authors said i can't remember
which republican in florida said this
but basically you can't have an issue
now under this law a teacher in third
grade
giving a word problem in math class
can't say jimmy and his two moms have
that's against the law under this law to
say jimmy and his two moms the reality
is there are same-sex parents in this
country the reality is there are gay
people in this country to deny a reality
is to diminish their existence which we
know based on data that that actually
has harmful mental health effects on
lgbtq individuals and families so
i want to make a distinction here or at
least delve into this distinction you're
saying that this bill is unfair toward
lgbt people are you referring to the
lgbt three-year-olds to seven-year-olds
that this bill would affect or are you
referring to the three-year-olds and
seven-year-olds who
whose sexuality we are not talking about
and are not interested in and i you know
i think it's a little creepy even to
talk about five-year-old sexuality but
maybe they've got their father is gay
and so they you know it's johnny has two
daddies or their mother is a lesbian or
something like that and so it's it's
disrespectful to them not to have the
math teacher talk about the lesbian
mothers when doing arithmetic
yeah well first things first it this
affects k through three so i don't think
kindergarten is three year olds now i
have kids no it's preschool it's pre-k
through through i apologize it's pre-k
through okay and then and third grade
goes all the way up to you could be nine
years old in in third grade as well
potentially depending on how well you do
in second grade
but um
so but but here's the deal
it it's this denying reality this is a
common problem that seems to be
happening in republican circles right
now book banning right we actually have
book banning happening in this country
you can't reject reality you can't
reject ideas that just because you
disagree that look you and i disagree
all the time does that mean michael that
i reject that your idea should not even
exist
in the public sphere
for fear that it's going to infect
others look i am 100
always have been against white
nationalism for example does that mean i
think that it should never exist well i
would like it to never exist do i think
that everything should be banned and
those people should not be allowed to
speak on that basis by government decree
that's what we're talking about so it's
not a it's not a choice that's being
made it's by government decree that
we're saying something can't be said in
a classroom that idea is should be
antithetical to most people on the right
but you get you mix religion into it and
suddenly people forget their core values
that they supposedly espouse and then
say now we can't say those words at all
in a public space now ethan are you
that's a problem on this topic of
banning books are you of the opinion
that no books should be banned from the
curriculum whatsoever
there's a difference between curriculum
and what's available in a library right
so we're talking i'm sorry we're talking
about the classroom though right you
know the math teacher talks about how
jane has two mommies we're talking about
the books that are being taught not
necessarily in a health class and not
just what's in a library but the the
sort of ideas and books that are being
brought into the classroom are you of
the opinion that no books should be
banned whatsoever
no
there are books that should be banned
and i would go back to the white
nationalist example i don't want any
white nationalist book taught in my k
through 3 school because but that should
still be potentially available in a
library somewhere if somebody wants to
read and argue that point right i don't
agree with it i don't like it it won't
be in my library but does that mean that
the government should put out a decree
that says it cannot be available no
um i don't agree with that so that's
where we are though in this circumstance
is the government is decreeing
that a teacher cannot do a word problem
in third grade that says jimmy and his
two moms
you're breaking the law and now we're
restricting teachers by the way florida
is also proposing putting cameras and
microphones on teachers too this this is
where the slippery slope on the right
seems to be wildly out of control
now ethan yeah but what what if i were
what if math teacher michael who is
catholic
and conservative what if i were teaching
students and i said okay so uh we're
gonna do an arithmetic problem here um
marriage as we all know is a sacred
union between one man and one woman so
you've got one man on one side and one
woman on the other what happens when you
add them together one plus one equals
two would with that statement should
that be banned from the classroom
no
it should not
so if if you think if you think that and
you believe that uh you can disagree
with it the the key here is
are you going to be preaching
catholicism in a public classroom now i
just did wow i just did but now you have
to allow then at the same time so
there's a difference if if it's
espousing a specific religious belief
and you don't allow a contradictory
opinion i think we have problems
so then okay then on that on that that's
a very good point
on that point when the left some leftist
teacher espouses a very specific
religious belief namely that it's
totally morally acceptable for
men and men to be the same as men and
women or that men can become women and
women can become men that's a religious
belief it's called
gnostic dualism among others of course
it's religious it's about the nature
of course i mean by ethan by definition
it's religious you're talking about the
nature of morality you're talking about
the nature of humanity you're talking
about the relationship between our soul
and our body how much more religious can
you get
yeah it's not because it's not part of a
catechism for example from a church
that's where you start church of leftism
i think ethan no that's not an official
church is that is that this is the state
church in this country
the irs runs it really isn't though so
that's a nonsensical argument that the
wright likes to use but the the issue
here still comes down to a key fact
there are gay people there are same
characters no one's denying i want to
deny that reality in a classroom to kids
because you somehow have a belief that
is so weak that you can't hear those
words and you don't have a strong enough
home where you're teaching them what you
believe your own children that they can
never hear something that contradicts
what you believe that's weakness by the
way the supreme court just under 100
years ago affirmed your right michael to
send your kids to a private catholic
school is actually over catholicism in
1925 that the supreme court ruled that
you have the right to send your kid to a
private school right
but ethan but ethan my taxpayer dollars
are going toward the public schools and
i think this is a pretty modest ask to
suggest that people who are little kids
who are three to seven or eight or even
for your slow second grade or nine years
old uh in these classrooms that they not
be exposed to radical theories about sex
and gender which have been held in moral
opprobrium by virtually every
civilization for all of human history
that they not be exposed to that before
they're even hitting the age of reason
this seems like a relatively minor ask
to me it seems like a pretty radical
political agenda on the other side
that's seeking to imbue the math
curriculum with transgenderism and novel
notions of marriage we've got we're
already passed down but i want to give
you the last word
yeah i i just disagree with that and
it's already not in the curriculum it's
prohibiting something that isn't even
happening and it's demeaning so the math
teacher is not talking a section of our
population the math teacher is not going
to say talk about johnny's two moms and
his dad who became a mother
it might now because you've made an
issue of it
well then i get i guess it's on us but
i'm glad there's a law at least to to
stop that kind of radicalism that
perhaps i guess we impelled it in the
first place but i'm glad we won't see
any more ethan where can people find you
just ethanberryman.com and you can find
me on twitter at ethan bearman ethan
thank you very much you have given me a
broader perspective of this law but i
still think you are entirely wrong thank
you for coming on ethan
thanks michael
all right now when you search for all
this kind of weird stuff like you know
gender and schools and all this kind you
don't want to see that on your browser
history you don't want the isps to know
that you're doing that which is why
you've got to check out expressvpn head
on over to expressvpn.com
knowles how did you choose your internet
service provider
i know how you chose it
for the vast majority of people you
didn't have a choice because the isps
operate like monopolies in the regions
they serve and they use that monopoly
power to take advantage of customers and
they log your internet activity and they
sell those data to other big tech
companies and advertisers
all those data even the stuff
that you're searching for on your little
incognito window you know things that
maybe you shouldn't be looking at
according to the powers that be you know
saucy websites like for instance the
daily wire
you don't want that stuff getting logged
when you go online use a vpn
it's as simple as that actually
yesterday when i was looking up some
things that were a little bit critical
of some of government's policies it
occurred to me as i was doing it oh my
gosh i forgot to turn my vpn on at the
top of this setting i turned it off
briefly just to kind of restart it i
renewed my subscription don't when you
go online use that vpn it's so easy with
expressvpn you just click one button on
your computer on your mobile device do
not hand over your data to bigtech go to
expressvpn.comr essvpn.com
knowles to get three extra months for
free expressvpn.com knowles head on over
there right now to learn more
shifting gears a little bit from
transgenderism in second grade
classrooms
i've got the craziest story
that i have seen in politics in
years i think the story has so many
levels of disinformation to it
i don't really know where to begin the
story is
the allegation
of bio labs
in ukraine u.s funded
biological laboratories
in ukraine the russian government
has has made an accusation that the us
is developing bioweapons and part of the
reason that they invaded ukraine was to
stop this development of bio weapons in
ukraine here is the russian government
official line
we have found
euro biological materiel
it was developed primarily for military
purposes as it turns out
it was all happening in ukraine what
were you doing there
it's a different continent
it has no borders with you
there are no bases
of yours
what
were they doing there under the guise of
scientific research
so we've got it we've found that the
americans and the ukrainians are working
together to build these biological
weapons
is this claim credible or not
the russians do know a thing or two
about chemical and biological weapons
the russians regularly use at least
chemical weapons against their own
people against political dissidence they
did it to the main opposition leader
they've done it to a number of people
who've fallen afoul of putin's regime
furthermore for
most of the history of the cold war the
soviets accused the united states of
developing biological weapons usually
without any basis there's actually a
letter that was sent from the soviet
central committee in 1953 just after the
death of stalin to the communist
dictator mao zedong they said for mao
zedong the soviet government and central
committee of the communist party of the
soviet union were misled the spread in
the press of information about the use
of amer by the americans of
bacteriological weapons in korea was
based on false information
the accusations against the americans
were fictitious so we know from the
russians themselves that they have a
very long history of making false
accusations about the americans and bio
weapons
but
what about these labs what about this
accusation the ukrainians came out and
immediately denied that any of this was
happening in the kiev post they wrote
recently fake news about the alleged
activities of american military
biological laboratories in ukraine has
been spread in the media and social
networks no foreign biological
laboratories operate in ukraine
statements recently made by individual
politicians are not true and are a
deliberate distortion of the facts
okay no
foreign biological laboratories exist in
ukraine this is bs fake news russian
propaganda so says ukraine the americans
are saying this too
so you've got the official
propagandists of the liberal regime here
in america politifact snopes the fact
checkers big tech the mainstream media
they're saying this is totally fake news
there are no here right here at the
sub-headline there are no u.s run bio
labs in ukraine contrary to social media
posts
and yet
just a couple days ago we played this on
the show yesterday the under secretary
of state for political affairs victoria
newland
admitted that there are in fact bio labs
in ukraine
ukraine has a
biological research facilities
which in fact we are now quite concerned
russian troops russian forces
may be seeking to
gain control of so we are working with
the ukrainians on how they can
prevent any of those
research materials from falling into the
hands of
russian forces should they approach
there are
biological and you can tell she didn't
want to
fully admit all of this and then rubio
diverted the questioning after that but
she said pretty clearly there are bio
labs in ukraine the relationship of the
us to those bio labs she doesn't quite
get into and she says we're very
concerned that those bio labs might fall
into the hands of the russians as they
invade ukraine
now
the u.s embassy in kiev
through a little video that was linked
actually from one of these fact-checker
websites
the u.s embassy in kiev admitted that
the u.s has a pretty tight connection
with these laboratories
the work we do in the biological threat
reduction program is is complicated and
it's difficult to communicate it
sometimes to
outside audiences and i think our
adversaries like russia can take
advantage of that with some of the
propaganda that they put out the
biological threat reduction program is
working in 27 countries we feel this
disinformation and misinformation is
done just to really exploit divisions
we've had accusations that some research
projects were being used to create
threats not to identify threats and
reduce them ulterior motives are being
injected where none exists we've built
these capabilities for the partners
their central reference labs for
research they publish everything they do
they invite the international community
into their laboratories they're working
on behalf and the benefit of
the people of their respective countries
so these labs look they're just
purely scientific research to prevent
threats and then the russian
disinformation they've gone out and
they've said this is some kind of
military operation to create biological
weapons and that's just completely
ridiculous okay this is where it gets
really really weird because at the end
of that video from the u.s embassy in
kiev the
the
presenter says for more information go
to
dtra.mil
dot military so you've been telling me
the whole time this is just purely a
scientific public health-minded endeavor
and yet now you're directing me to a
military website because this program is
being run by the pentagon it's being run
by the department of defense okay this
is where it gets weird yesterday i said
okay i'm going to look into this i go to
the dtra.mil website
the website was down
i looked on
archive.org which will show you various
screenshots of websites when they were
online what the pages looked like and
when they go offline
the page had been up just a couple days
prior
i asked other people i said here's go to
this website what do you say i tried on
multiple devices the website was
down
you can use different vpns to make have
you coming through different different
ports of entry to look at the website
the website was down just one day after
victoria nuland gave her testimony about
this
then a few hours later it goes back up
then you go over i said okay i want more
information about this program because
the argument that is being made now by
the pentagon is this all dates back to a
2005 treaty that was signed under george
w bush to dismantle old soviet bio
weapons laboratories the soviets had
developed these bio weapons after the
fall of the soviet union
about 14 years later we we go in there
into ukraine into georgia into all these
other eastern bloc countries and we're
gonna very safely protect and dismantle
these bio weapons programs so then i
went over to the state department
website where i could find links on the
internet to the funding grants
but all the
links had been deleted
you couldn't get it there you had to go
to old versions of the the
details of these grants and so you look
i mean there were about 11 or 12 of
these on on the internet you've got them
for the kharkivo blast laboratory center
in kharkiv you've got the levive oblast
laboratory center leve you've got the
i'm mispronouncing all of these names
the state regional diagnostic veterinary
laboratory and all of the funding is
coming from not from the national
institutes of health not from the cdc
not from the world health organization
not from usaid it's coming from donor
the department of defense the united
states of america donor the department
of defense of the united states of
america donor the united states defense
threat reduction agency on
and on and on so what
exactly is going on with these labs who
who is telling the truth and if no one's
telling the truth what is the truth
about these laboratories
we're very excited to announce that this
weekend ben shapiro is hosting a new
interview on the sunday special that's
an interview with bill maher it's only
available to daily wire subscribers
early starting saturday morning so get
ready for an entire weekend of amazing
content only at the daily wire tonight
is the night tonight is the premiere of
our next big hit
the hyperions the pre-show begins at 8
30 p.m eastern so make sure you head
over to daily wires youtube channel set
a reminder to catch the live showing
it's not woke it has zero agenda it
could not care less about your pronouns
because when it comes to entertainment
just having fun is really all that
matters check out the trailer
[Music]
my name
is vista mandelbaum
my brother and i have taken four
hostages everybody against the wall
we've come for one thing
our titan badges
is this real yes ma'am
it's the police they want to talk to
whoever's in charge
[Music]
this titan badge can grant an individual
superhuman power
perhaps it's time for someone else to
take on the responsibility
meet apollo
i'd recommend next time using your power
yeah i mean yeah if you think so
calling all hyperions
on my way
you're making such a mess in here
we've got a hyperion in roots not a good
time to look stupid
[Applause]
she's trying to destroy me
next question how's the family the
family is um
gosh what is it
marvelous
[Music]
we will be streaming the film once
tonight at 8 30 eastern for all of
youtube to see so be sure to head on
over to daily ware's youtube channel set
a reminder for the live showing after
that you got to be a member to get in on
the action go to
subscribe so you don't miss any more of
the growing cache of content
that we have to offer we'll be right
back with a lot more
the bio labs in ukraine get even weirder
the russians are accusing the united
states of developing biological weapons
and using ukraine as the ground on which
they're going to do it the chinese are
saying that we have hundreds of these
centers all over the world the united
states says we're not developing
bioweapons this is disinformation this
is not a military effort we are actually
preventing threats and we're conducting
ordinary scientific research to help the
public health so what exactly is going
on well
one organization that is at the heart of
these bio labs these and other bio labs
is eco health ecohealth does that name
sound familiar it's familiar because
that was the organization that was
associated with dr fauci that it was at
the heart of the gain of function
research in conjunction with the wuhan
institute of virology just before the
kovid 19 pandemic broke out ecohealth
the organization run by peter dashak who
was dr fauci's gain of function guy who
dr fauci gave a lot of money to to
conduct gain of function research
eco health has received huge contracts
from the pentagon they've gotten
41.91 million dollars in awards since
fiscal year 2008. so the pentagon is the
biggest funder of eco health alliances
not the nih that's the biggest funder
it's not the public health apparatus
it's the the defense department
that they they're getting three times as
much money from the pentagon as they
have from any other organization in the
government the next highest one is the
department of health and human services
now of this
for almost 42 million dollars
a little under 38 million dollars of
that was awarded to eco-health alliance
by the defense threat reduction agency
the dtra the the agency listed at the
end of that video by the u.s embassy in
kiev describes the mission as quote to
protect the united states and its allies
by enabling the dod and international
partners to detect deter and
defeat weapons of mass destruction and
threat networks
i am not denying that there is possibly
some reasonable explanation for all of
this
but what is it what is it i don't know
because initially what we were told by
the entire
liberal establishment by
big tech and the fact checkers and the
government officials and everyone is
there are no bio weapons in ukraine
that's what ukraine was saying there are
rather there are no bio labs in ukraine
ukraine says there's no foreign bio labs
politifact says there are no u.s run
labs well the language here is really
clear because what the ukraine is saying
is well there's no foreign labs what if
it's a domestic lab that a foreign
government happens to be very involved
in that might be the way they're getting
out of that politifact says there's no
u.s run labs well what if it's a lab
that is largely run by the ukrainians
but is funded and was in part built by
the united states there it falls apart i
think the language is pretty clear so
the question is are there u.s funded
labs and what is the funding going
toward initially they tell us there's no
bio labs forget about it it's totally
fake news okay actually there are bio
labs but it has nothing to do with the
united states then they say okay it's
got something to do with the united
states the u.s funds them and built them
in some cases actually spent millions
and millions of dollars rebuilding these
labs but it's only to dismantle the old
soviet bio weapons how long does it take
to dismantle bio weapons the soviet
union collapsed in 1991. this deal went
into effect much later in 2005 but even
still it's been 17 years since 2005. how
much longer is it going to take to
dismantle these things well no they're
not going to dismantle them entirely
they're going to just safely protect
store them and conduct some research on
them okay well if you're conducting
research on these biological weapons
that seems to be kind of dangerous
doesn't no no they say it's not a big
deal all of the research that's going on
there is completely mundane and that's
why it's such a big threat if the
russians get a hold of it well hold on a
second here if it's just totally
ordinary scientific research who cares
if the russians get a hold of it that
doesn't seem like it would be that
dangerous unless we're talking about
very very dangerous biological materials
well look even if that is a problem this
has nothing to do with a military action
this is entirely just scientific which
is why the whole damn thing is funded by
the pentagon doesn't add up it doesn't
add up and and i'm really not saying
that there couldn't possibly be some
good explanation for this
what i am saying is
the government has not provided one
the press
the broader propaganda machine has not
provided a good answer they've provided
lots of contradictory answers
that are extremely dishonest and then
when the facts come out it completely
undermines the credibility of the
government on the next claim that it
makes so what
is going
on here and and furthermore why lie
about it why do you keep lying about it
whenever anyone asks these questions
we're accused of spreading propaganda or
disinformation no i'm trying to cut
through all of the disinformation i want
to cut through putin's disinformation i
want to cut through china's
disinformation and yes i want to cut
through the disinformation of our own
deep state i want to cut through the
disinformation of the united states so
that i have some
idea of what the truth of the matter is
here we're not going to be able to come
up with solutions to the particular
problem in ukraine to broader geo
strategic issues unless we know even
just a little bit of what is actually
going on here
the government has
some explaining to do now you want to
talk about good statesmanship
president trump was just caught on a
hidden camera speaking to
a you know very very famous golf star so
this is not a high-level government
meeting he's just talking to a buddy of
his and the conversation was secretly
recorded he is describing how he dealt
with vladimir putin
you know
he was a friend of mine i got along
great with him i say vladimir if you're
doing we're hitting moscow i said we're
going to hit moscow and he sort of
believed me like 5 10 that's all you
need he never did it during my time john
you know no you're not talking about it
no it's funny
in the last four years
it's funny how she didn't bother you
either
yeah no she didn't bother me i told him
the same thing
that'll be next
yeah you know that's going to be next
time one will be next you won't have any
computer chips they'll blow them off the
face of the air
so this is a casual conversation about
all the bumbles from joe biden
the most interesting part to me is that
five to ten percent
he says look putin i'm gonna hit moscow
and he believed me he believed me five
to ten percent which is enough
right trump is not boasting here that he
completely 100 convinced putin that he
would hit moscow
in the event of an invasion of ukraine
he's not even saying
that he 100 wasn't going to do it
he's saying
all i had to do was convince putin that
there was a five to ten percent chance
that i would bomb moscow
the lesson here is
unpredictability
is an extremely powerful political asset
and the problem one of the biggest
problems right now with the current
occupant of the oval office is he is 100
completely predictable
it's not even the specific policies all
of which are terrible but it's just that
we know exactly what he's going to do
all the time and that gives our foreign
adversaries a huge advantage because
they can plan ahead
and they can plan not just an invasion
of a country but they can plan four or
five steps ahead because they know that
all biden is going to do is the usual
classical typical establishment
playbook
trump was not like that
i don't think people believed that it
was very likely that trump would go in
and
bomb moscow
go in and invade some country he ran as
a fairly anti-war candidate
but they believed there was a chance
every so often he'd go take out an
iranian general
out of the blue and even a lot of the
establishment didn't like that he did
that every so often he dropped the
mother of all bombs on a country and
just you didn't
and he tried to minimize deaths in that
but he would just he would do
wild things he would tweet out hey i've
got a bigger nuclear button than yours
kim jong-un and my button's bigger and
it works
you think the guy's threatening world
war three that unpredictable you just
need that little bit five to ten percent
it's true in show business you don't
tune into shows
where you know exactly word for word on
every single issue what some guy is
going to say
you don't do it
even if you generally agree with the guy
because you you
want there to be some kind of tension
some unpredictability something that you
could learn
something that he knows that you don't
know
same is true
in politics much ironic people are
making fun of this clip unironically
this is much better statesmanship than
anything we were seeing from biden or
the people around biden
now
what what is extremely predictable is
that the white house is of course coming
out against this bill that i was just uh
debating with my friend ethan barron
they take an even stronger stance on the
bill than ethan does they say that this
sex ed bill this parental rights and
education bill is horrifying
discriminatory
and bullying
regarding the florida bill um in 1994
when many of us in this room were in
school president biden actually voted
for a much broader restriction
that banned federal funds from being
used for quote the promotion of
homosexuality as a positive lifestyle
alternative
why did he do that and can you describe
how his thinking has evolved over the
years well i think that you have seen
the president speak passionately about
his view
that a bill like this
a bill that would
discriminate against families against
kids
put these kids in a position of not
getting the support they need
at a time where that's exactly what they
need is discriminatory it's
a form of bullying
it is horrific i mean the president has
spoken to that in terms of his views and
comments from 25 years ago i think the
most important question now is why are
florida leaders deciding they need to
discriminate against kids who are
members of the lgbtqi community what
prompts them to do that is it meanness
is it wanting to make kids have more
difficult times in school in their
communities i would pose that question
to them and we can talk about it more
tomorrow if you get an answer
it's horrifying it's bullying it's
discriminatory it's mean it's cruel
that's the white house's line this was
the this was the crucial mistake that
ethan made in trying to
make his argument opposing the bill is
he said it's not even happening this was
the this was the mistake that the
critical race theory defenders were
making early on in that political battle
they said it's not even happening it's
not even in the classrooms so why are
you trying to ban it
and of course the natural response to
that is okay if it's not happening then
don't worry about it it's not a big deal
it's not happening
so who cares
and and ethan caught that at the end and
so he said well i but it might happen
now
but well that's true it's not a big deal
if
if the
bill is banning something that doesn't
exist then no one would reasonably be
upset about it the reason people are
upset is because this is happening
what is happening in
math classrooms i thought that was a
good example that ethan gave because
it's not just sex ed it's not just
history or literature it's in math
classrooms it's throughout the entire
school curriculum
kids are being taught
lgbt sexual theories
as young as three years old four years
old five years old
really really young kids are being
taught
that men and women are basically exactly
the same and marriage maybe is between
one man and one woman maybe it's between
one man and one man maybe it's between
one woman and one woman men and women
are pretty much interchangeable well
that's why men can become women that's
why women can become men that's why
transgenderism is totally normal and hey
little johnny if you feel like little
jane today we're gonna go talk to the
guidance counselor and we're gonna start
calling you little jane and your parents
have no rights whatsoever to oppose that
sort of thing
no
reasonable person would defend that
okay we've got to get that out of the
classroom and the point that ethan would
not concede to me although i think it's
fairly obvious is
this is a religious point of view
it's a religious point of view to say
the this definition of marriage is good
and moral and upstanding
it's a religious point of view to say
that the relationship between the human
soul and the body is such that i can
change my body to a better accord with
my soul because my soul is female and my
body is male that's a deeply religious
point of view it's called the gnostic
dualism it's a very ancient religious
heresy
and so they're already teaching that
kind of religion in the classroom and
what a lot of parents are saying who are
christian who are jews who are muslims
who are maybe somewhat agnostic but
they've still got a little bit of that
old kind of cultural religion in them
they say hey i i'd rather my kids be
taught that boys or boys and girls or
girls that's my view i want them raised
that way and and what
what the radicals in the classroom are
saying is no
those religious views are completely
banned the only book that you're not
allowed to teach in the classroom is the
bible you can teach mind conf but you
can't teach the bible
those views are banned and the other
religious views that boys can become
girls those are mandatory and if you
ever try to kick that out of the
classroom it's mean and discriminatory
and horrifying and that's it's
it obviously is happening in the
classroom because this is being elevated
not just from some school battle in
florida this is being elevated all the
way up to the highest levels in the
government this is being elevated all
the way up to the white house if this
isn't really happening if this isn't a
big deal if this is just some crazy tiny
little trivial obsession for republicans
why is the white house so obsessed with
it it's a question you gotta ask
yourself who cares the left cares the
left seems to care a whole lot maybe the
right should care too
the disney ceo down in florida he's very
disappointed
oh boy is he disappointed in this law
banning creepy sex stuff from the
classroom disney ceo bob chapic has
called on governor desantis uh he's he
said he's very disappointed
he wants the governor not to sign this
legislation he's donating 5 million
bucks
to gay causes
and he's trying to
stop this kind of legislation from
spreading across the country
i cannot wait
for governor desantis
to lay the political body slam on this
guy and say no
the perverts who want to indoctrinate
five-year-olds into transgenderism they
don't get to do it there are naturally
limits in the classroom there are always
going to be limits in the classroom and
that's just the way it goes we're we're
not going to have the limits be you can
discuss anything from
you can discuss anything from lng to t
which is
pretty much the current limit in the
classroom no we're going to say the
limits are you don't get to
in
inculcate this uh ideology of
transgenderism in six-year-olds i think
desantis is going to stand firm weaker
politicians when they get calls from
powerful corporate interests in their
state they cave asa hutchinson and
arkansas did it on this issue
christine in south dakota did it on this
issue until she realized it almost
destroyed her political career and she
flipped back ron desantis i don't think
he's going to do it i think he's a lot
smarter this issue is a winner for
conservatives
just look at the polls
look at the polls on
not just even these issues
not just even transgenderism or critical
race theory in the classroom on pretty
much all of the hot button social issues
we've talked a lot about immigration
that's a total winner for conservatives
who want to restrict not just illegal
but legal immigration as well abortion
is at least a draw and when you talk
about limits to abortion not from the
moment of conception but even
15 weeks six weeks 15 weeks 20 weeks
then it's a huge winner for
conservatives transgenderism in the
classroom huge winner for conservatives
critical race theory huge winner for
conservatives same as to a voter id
there's a new rasmussen poll out that
asked voters if it was reasonable to ask
voters to present some form of photo id
before they cast their vote the vast
majority of likely voters said yes that
includes
a majority
of democrats three-quarters of likely
voters say that voter id is a reasonable
measure
only 20 percent say that it is not
it's a huge
spread
now 90
of republicans
say that this is a reasonable measure
there's no surprise there but 59 of
democrats say the same thing
and yet
the squishes will tell you all back away
from voter id oh don't lean into the
social issues what are you talking about
i think they have bought too much of the
cnn msnbc
mainstream liberal narrative here
the cnn the msnbc the nbc new york times
they will concern troll republicans
by concern trolling i mean they'll say
look it's for your own good republicans
if you want to win elections you better
cut it out with all this talk about
voter id you better cut because that's
not going to work for you and i'm just
so concerned i a partisan democrat
who've never even considered voting for
a republican in my entire life i'm just
really look if there were a sane
republican i might vote for one
i if there were if you guys got back to
nominating
i don't know
john kasich for every position maybe i'd
still vote for the democrat but i'd be
happier because you'd have a total loser
being nominated on the other side
but you know you crazy republicans
that's just not going to play well
i think it plays great i think the
squishy republicans that the democrats
keep encouraging us to nominate i think
they all lose i think they're complete
losers because people are not motivated
primarily by lowering the marginal
corporate tax rate people don't wake up
in a cold sweat in the middle of the
night and say gosh golly i've just got
to sign another free trade agreement
with asia
people are motivated by hey are my kids
being indoctrinated in this creepy sex
stuff hey are my kids being taught that
white people are evil but because of the
color of their skin from the moment of
birth
i think they wake up with that hey are
my elections fair hey can i trust my own
government hey are gas prices going up
or down
really basic stuff okay
when the liberal media
concerns roll you and tell you oh guys
just drop this to the voter id drop this
drop abortion drop transgenderism drop
critical race theory that's when you
know
you really should double down
so who's going to be running who are we
going to be running against in 2024 you
know i have said and i'm
a shiver even at the thought
that hillary might not be finished yet
well hillary just went on msnbc she said
emphatically i'm not interested in
running
are you
open to running for president again
oh come on just know long run no but
well
no but i am certainly going to be active
in supporting women running for office
and other
candidates
who
i think should be re-elected or elected
both women and men
because i think you know there's a big
debate going on as you know so well mika
in our country but in other countries as
well about the future
of democracy of economic opportunity of
climate change of health and other
important issues so i i will stay active
uh in uh all of those debates
yes no
i'm not at all interested in running for
president that's why i keep going on tv
and that's why i just relaunched the
clinton global initiative and that's why
i keep writing and speaking about my
views on paula
but i would never run don't believe it
don't as a as a rule don't ever believe
the clintons that's just never going to
lead you into the right direction
she may not run
she may run here's what i know though
here's what i know
almost everything that the liberal
establishment has told us
the swamp creatures have told us for the
past five years going all the way back
to the russia hoax and pretty much
everything since then has been a lie and
there is no creature swampier than
hillary clinton and hillary clinton was
actually the instigator of that original
the russia hoax in the first place and
hillary clinton is doing everything you
would expect her to do if she were
trying to set herself up to run for
president in 2024.
on that terrifying note i'm michael
knowles this is the michael knowles show
see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadofsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022.
today on the ben shapiro show the legacy
media parrot democratic talking points
about a bill banning indoctrination of
children into left-wing sexual and
gender values and they are pushing
disney to condemn the state of florida
that's today on the ben shapiro show
give it a listen